hi everyone sal khan here welcome to the
homeroom with sal livestream we have a
very very exciting conversation today
with jennifer duna the 2020 nobel prize
winner in chemistry for what has often
been described as one of the most
important discoveries in the history of
biology or maybe in the history of
science and we'll talk about why that is
it could actually forever change what it
even what it means to be human but
before we go into into that i will give
my standard announcements reminder that
we are a not-for-profit khan academy so
if you're in a position to do so please
think about going to khan academy.org
slash donate donations of all size make
a huge difference also want to give a
special shout out to several
organizations that stepped up uh
especially during kovid when they
realized more people were depending on
us and
we were running at a deficit special
thanks to bank of america at t
google.org novartis fastly and it was
just announced yesterday general motors
for very very generous support to make
to allow us to help millions of y'all uh
keep learning uh in this year and and
last year uh also want to remind you
that there's a podcast version of this
live stream wherever you get your
podcast homeroom with sal the podcast
with that i'm very very excited to
introduce jennifer
who is a you are the lee kashing
chancellor's chair professor at the
department of chemistry and department
of molecular and cell ball you have a
very long title department of solid
molecular logic at the university of
california berkeley you got the 2020
nobel prize in chemistry for your work
with crispr thank you so much for
joining us
thanks for inviting me sal great to be
here
so
for those of you for those of y'all
watching who have not heard of crispr
this will be i predict 100 years in the
future
all of the other craziness of 2020 will
kind of
not be remembered as much as
the work that jennifer and her
colleagues have done over the last
several years in crispr jennifer you
know
for for those of you who are unfamiliar
with it you know what what's kind of the
headline or the
the cliff notes version of what crispr
is and why it's important
well i guess i would start by saying
it's a technology for genome editing
what does that mean well it's a tool
that scientists are using to make
precise changes to the dna in a cell or
a whole organism that can lead to
alterations in the genetic makeup of the
of the cell or the or the resulting
organism so we're ah you got the video
here we're seeing
the crispr system in action so it it's a
protein that purple blob with
a little zip code molecule in it a piece
of rna
that allows binding to a 20 letter
sequence in the dna of a cell and so you
can see the
guide rna
marking the site and then dna getting
cut that's the key activity of crispr
and what that does is to induce
a dna repair pathway in cells that
allows cells to alter
the dna sequence at that precise
position and in the example we just saw
in the video there was insertion of a
new piece of dna
that could allow cells to acquire a new
gene or even a new set of genes and this
is all now being controlled by
scientists so we can manipulate genes in
ways that were previously very difficult
or impossible
yeah and for those watching who didn't
fully appreciate how powerful what some
of what you just said is
you know obviously our i mean we're
living systems everything else is you
know
all living systems have uh dna
and you know you have these long
sequences of dna parts of them those are
individual genes that can code for
proteins or sets of proteins and now
using crispr you all have introduced a
technology that can
help us
edit dna
you know before i go into all of the
implications positive and potentially
you know ones that we have to wonder
about
i'm curiou i'm i'm curious about how
your pathway to to to kind of
discovering this when
when did it first dawn on you that
something like this could happen and
what was and and how it and and how hard
or easy was it to get to the place that
you got to
well you know sal what i love about
crispr one of the one of the things is
the is the origin story because this is
really a technology that came out of a
fundamental
curiosity driven project it was small
science not not big science it was
science being done by a handful of
laboratories
and in our own lab at university of
california berkeley we were
investigating crispr which was
originally discovered to be a bacterial
immune system a way that bacteria can
detect and destroy viruses
and when i heard about this from my
colleague jillian banfield at berkeley
probably a dozen years ago now i was
fascinated i wondered well how does that
work and so we began investigating it
about
people have known about crispr fort for
some time if this you know it stands for
clustered regularly interspaced short
palindromic repeats but but really what
that is is these bacteria would have
these sequences of
of what would be dna or rna and it would
dna and it would have pieces of kind of
ancient other viruses in it and so it
would use those as kind of that that
tagging location uh sequence the way
that you just described in that previous
visual to kind of cut viral dna is that
what it was doing
yes that's right and and by the way not
necessarily ancient pieces of virus
either this is a system that works in
real time so during an infection
a bacterial cell could acquire
a dna sequence from a virus and then use
it as the template to make a guide rna
molecule that allows this kind of
searching that you're seeing going on
here by the cas9 protein
so this is a you know a system that
started as a you know as a fundamental
biology project
but once emanuel charpentier our
collaborator and our lab figured out how
the cas9 protein works as a dna cleaver
we could see how it could be harnessed
as a genome editing technology and
that's really what's taken off over the
last eight years
when did you first learn about crispr
and that these uh that bacteria were
using it in order to be a viral defense
mechanism and it dawned on you that hey
maybe that could be used to edit dna
when was this and then how long before
you started making some significant
progress on that
i think i first heard about crispr in
the mid-2000s
from uh from ben from jillian banfield
at berkeley who was researching this in
in bacteria she was looking at
dna sequences in bacteria she was one of
the first
laboratories to realize that bacteria
were
acquiring dna and storing it
in their own genetic material in real
time in response to viral infections
sort of a fascinating
observation and at that time it was a
hypothesis
that this might be some kind of immune
system and that's really where we got
involved
and initially
you know were you like this is like a a
five percent chance were of this
actually leading to anything did people
think that you were
kind of you know going down a on a wild
goose chase or or was it apparent pretty
early that no this is this is a big idea
little of both i guess you know i i
certainly felt like it was a very
interesting biological phenomenon that i
wanted to pursue
at the same time i was
a little bit nervous about
you know using
biomedical research funding to work on
this because it wasn't entirely clear
where it was headed in in terms of
ultimate outcomes
and i can remember getting a few strange
looks at scientific meetings when i
first began talking about our work on
crispr because at that time
almost nobody had heard of it and it
sounded like a real niche area of
biology
what was the moment and when was the
moment where you said
oh my god this works
this works
and i'm sure you know uh i i you know
one of my favorite papers which i'm sure
you're very familiar with is you know
watson and crick's paper where they
found the structure of the double helix
structure of dna which is a one and a
half page paper at the end they say it
is not i think they say something like
it has not passed our attention the
implications of this work um when was
that moment for you when did it happen
and what did it just feel like and how
did you know that that you you'd kind of
gotten to something
well it was somewhat of a continuum i
would say you know towards the end of
the 2000s we were working on various
different
aspects of the crispr system and
bacteria mostly doing
biochemical experiments in the lab
meaning working with purified proteins
and rnas and dna molecules to figure out
the chemistry of how they work together
and uh and then you know that work
really culminated in the work that we
published in 2012 where we described the
way that the cas9 protein works as an
rna guided molecular scissors that can
cut dna at a desired place and
importantly that we as scientists could
control where the cutting happens by
programming it with these molecules of
rna and i think for us that was really
the you know the um the publication that
where we were able to point out that
this could be used as a gene editing
tool
and and i just want to make sure i
understand that actually you could move
over a little bit i think to the right
uh your
uh your your cameras
much better much much better um
you know just make sure i understand
what makes the science so it makes sense
to me that you have this kind of protein
enzyme complex that has a you know
strand of of rna on it and that rna can
find the complementary part of dna and
then this protein is able to cut there
and maybe in another place
as well maybe based on another rna
strand how do you insert is that i mean
in that visual we saw that there was
that step where um i mean does you know
does the dna just kind of
float in
and if you put the right enzymes it'll
attach how does that insertion work or
was that part easy did people already
know how to do that
no not that part is not easy and in fact
that's that's a great question sal
because it really gets to the heart of
this technology because because
importantly crispr is a cutter it's a
cutting technology
and the actual genome editing happens in
the cell when the cell uses its repair
proteins to fix the broken dna so in
that example that we saw that
illustrates how
in a cell a broken piece of dna could be
repaired
by inserting a new section of dna and
there are whole sets of proteins in
cells that are responsible for that kind
of chemistry
and in truth we don't fully understand
you know how to how to control that
reaction in the cells but uh but we know
that cells are very good at detecting
broken dna and fixing it and so that's
there and there are different ways to
kind of try to you know encourage cells
to do the dna repair in a particular way
such as inserting a section of dna to
make that kind of desired genome edit
you know the thing we always like to
emphasize you know whenever i make a
video on chemistry or biology khan
academy you know in textbooks you kind
of
they kind of make you believe that these
these proteins have brains of their own
and they know exactly where to zero in
on but these are these you know uh
thermodynamic chemical systems where
things are just constantly vibrating and
colliding with each other and some of
those collisions stick if the right kind
of things can get close enough with not
too much energy to the right things and
enough energy too sometimes um and so
it's all this random stuff happening and
so yeah i definitely i can conceptualize
how the enzyme and the rna they're part
of this complex you know at some point
they're going to run into the right part
of the dna they cut and and then yeah
how do we get that right dna sequence in
there and it sounds like
it is a little bit stochastic you could
have uh some of the dna might just
repair but if you are able to kind of
have those dna fragments around in the
presence of the right enzymes some of
that will get stuck in as well
yes exactly and so because of that you
know scientists are trying to manipulate
the conditions of these gene editing
experiments so that we get the desired
outcome whether it's insertion of a new
section of dna or
disruption of a small
you know sequence such as a single base
pair
and there's already a lot of questions
coming in uh i think a lot of people are
able to extrapolate what this could do
for better or or for worse maybe in
certain circumstances so from facebook
michelle fury is asking can this can
this be done to adults can the dna
editing be done to adults or only to
embryos which goes to this you know can
it be done for somatic cells which we
have trillions of or do you have to kind
of get something at the embryonic stage
great question michelle so you know the
answer is that the vast majority of
genome editing
for people
is going to be in my opinion you know
certainly for the foreseeable future
will be in adults or or kids but
certainly not in embryos and and so you
might wonder well how does that work
and typically it would be a treatment
where cells that can regenerate or even
create a new tissue
would be the ones being edited so i'll
give you an example
sickle cell disease is a well-known
genetic disorder of the blood that
results from a single mutation in a gene
that encodes one of this essential
proteins for carrying oxygen in our red
blood cells
and so with sickle cell disease crispr
can be used to make correcting mutations
just in those cells that give rise to
new red blood cells and so that's a way
that this the therapy can be used in
uh in patients in a way where it impacts
the patient but not anybody else
and how is that done is that done uh by
introducing the enzyme
you know directly into the cell somehow
or does it have like a vec a kind of a
harmless virus that can kind of take it
in how do you introduce it into
uh the the somatic cells the body cells
these you know potentially trillions of
cells that might be involved here
yeah well right now the way it's being
done is by taking those blood precursor
cells we call them blood stem cells out
of a patient and doing the genome
editing in the laboratory so it can and
and the you know the crispr protein and
its guiding rna can be introduced
in different ways it can be put in as a
as a directly assembled molecular
complex of the protein and the rna or it
can be put in as you mentioned cell
using
uh what we call a vector for example a
virus that can encode those materials
oh so y'all will take the stem cells out
and i mean when you're able to do it
like a you're not doing one cell at a
time you're able to do like
blobs of it i guess i think that's a
technical right globs
by either with a virus or introducing it
and and you know i am curious because i
know i've you know i've i've had uh you
could tell people i hang out with i've
had debates with my friends overnight
about you know when you when you do it
the way you just described it affects
that one individual and hopefully it
cures them of sickle cell which could be
a very bad disease so that's huge uh
there's the other possibility of you're
going to the germ line you're either
going directly to an embryo or you're
going to the cells that produce the
sperms and the eggs
and then that in theory you're affecting
the gene pool
uh and so one question is you know does
is that doable
and then what are your thoughts on that
because there's a possibility of
removing sickle cell from the gene pool
entirely uh uh but but where do you see
the the puts and takes there
right so this is this is uh what you
just described is what we call germline
or germ cell editing and and we call
them germ cells because they're
literally able to
give rise to many more cells that are of
a particular type
so uh or you know you can create a whole
whole organism like a whole human being
and um and and the reason that that is
in my view a much more profound
use of crispr is that it creates what we
call a heritable change in the dna so it
affects not just the individual but
their all of their their kids and their
kids kids
now
you know if you could remove a harmful
gene from the the human population
and that would obviously take time but
you know you could in principle do this
using
genome editing and it could be a it
could be argued that you know there
might be cases where that would be
desirable
but i think right now for many reasons
some of them are technical and of course
there are many ethical implications i
think most scientists feel that that is
not an appropriate use of crispr in
humans right now and that we should
focus on somatic cell editing
and this is already leading to if if i i
remember being at a conference and
someone was talking about this there are
already people being treated for sickle
cell uh because of yes
right it's extraordinary it's very
exciting for all of us working in the
field to see
this work already benefiting patients
and we know there will be many more to
benefit in the future
absolutely and and on the ethics of this
question from facebook jeffrey kritzberg
is asking who should decide the ethics
of of the science just because we can
should we the butterfly effect
uh may not be a strong enough analogy
and i think what he's referring to is
you could edit one gene it seems to do
one thing but you know these are complex
systems and obviously there was that uh
i don't know if folks know there was
that case in china where a scientist you
know kind of went rogue used this
technology to edit an embryo to have a
more resistance towards aids and
actually i read that that scientist was
put in prison because of the the
questionable ethics of this so one how
do you you know it seems like the cat's
out of the bag uh this this is something
that can be done by scientists anywhere
you don't need billions of dollars of
capital to do crispr um
who do you think should decide it what
do you think is going to happen as you
know if there's countries jurisdictions
where people don't care
how how can we regulate this type of
thing
i think so first of all
thanks for the question jeffrey i think
the um situation with crispr is is
is in a way analogous to what we see for
a number of types of technologies
whether they're in the biological
sciences or or in technology
uh computing you know with uh for
example artificial intelligence where
the question is
the technology is powerful there are
many opportunities to use it to do
things that will be beneficial to
humanity but there also are risks and
how how do we control those risks and
who decides about uses and i guess you
know for me with crispr i i feel
strongly that it has to you know that
those decisions
really do need to be made by um by uh by
all the stakeholders that are involved
so in the end that kind of means all of
us
and and that will require scientists to
engage and discuss the science itself
and and the you know kind of the way the
technology works
and also to work closely with regulators
and um all sorts of groups that are
thinking about in in this case how
genome editing could impact
people
in the future
so that we can make responsible
decisions and that sounds you know hard
and it is
but i think a way to start is by
engaging the scientific community
globally
to think about this and work on it
together and i've been actually very
pleased over the last few years that
in discussions that i started with my
colleagues back in i think was 2015
we've been able to engage with now the
world health organization with unesco
and with many of the scientific
societies around the world to come
together there have been many
conferences and
committees that have been convened to
look into this and we now have i think a
very good framework for using crispr in
different settings going forward
and
tons of questions are coming in because
this is such a fascinating topic you
know i'm i'm curious and there's several
questions along this lines
well one uh beyond sickle cell where do
you think is the next obvious you know
sickle cell seems seems it is very
compelling because it's one mutation as
you mentioned it seems to have a clear
negative uh if you can fix it clear
positive uh what are the next things
that you think crispr will be able to
influence and i am also curious i think
everyone watching is curious
what's the next frontier for you where
do you think this can go next what's
your research now on
well um
i'll start with the first question so
you know there are a few thousand human
diseases that are well known to be
caused by a single genetic mutation a
single gene
whose correction could lead to a
therapeutic benefit so those are our i
think obvious initial targets for crispr
the big challenge is the challenge of
delivery which means how do we get the
crisper molecules into the cells that
need editing
so the example of sickle cell is a good
one because it provides a a way to do
the editing
outside of the patient because of the
you know the need to edit the cells of
the blood which can be easily found and
then you know taken into the laboratory
and edited and then replaced
but what if we wanted to edit a gene in
brain cells or in heart cells or muscle
cells you know it's a lot harder to do
that in the patient so that's i think in
many ways where
the bottleneck is right now in the
genome editing field
so so in terms of you know the next
maybe near-term targets for crispr i
certainly think other blood disorders
will be addressed as well as diseases of
the eye because this is again a tissue
where potentially one can deliver the
crispr molecules locally by injection
and maybe in the not too distant future
maybe a few years from now we'll see
therapies for muscular dystrophy coming
along there are a number of groups and
companies that are working very actively
on muscular dystrophy because
of the um of the potential to deliver
crispr molecules into muscle cells doing
and doing that using viruses that
specifically go into into muscle cells
but in terms of my own research i'm you
know i'm continuing to work on the
fundamentals of crispr and understanding
how it works but we're also engaging
increasingly in this challenge of
delivery because i think that for me as
a scientist i really want to see this
technology be affordable and available
to everybody around the world that needs
it that's a tall order but i think one
step towards doing that is making sure
that we can deliver it into a cell type
where it can be beneficial
and you know it's important to note
we've talked a lot about the
implications for crispr to kind of
change and maybe you know quote improve
but maybe sometimes
people could go rogue it also allows us
to understand
you know one of the main one of the main
things where we're so afraid to edit
genetics is because it's such a complex
system but obviously outside of humans
you could do it in other models and in
other animals or in bacteria uh you
could now edit and and kind of run uh
you know kind of a b testing the way
that you do in software like what if i
change this how does that happen what if
i change this what if i change this and
this is are you seeing that type of
research accelerate dramatically because
of crispr
hugely hugely i mean this is this is
something that over the last eight years
we've just seen research taking off at
an extraordinary pace doing exactly what
you just said cell because now that we
have this technology for precise
manipulation of one or even many genes
in in cells
in the laboratory it's an incredible
tool it means that we can now manipulate
genes and understand gene functions
in ways that previously would have been
very difficult or in some cases
impossible really to to figure out
yeah and you know in the time we have we
have a lot of young people watching and
a lot of parents of young people have
this question from facebook carol smith
capper um a paraphrase they have a son
who uh works who wants to do uh what
actually i just lost the question um who
well i'll paraphrase
who has who who wants to go into this
type of a field what would you say to a
young person who's fascinated by this
you know i've heard people say what what
computing has been the last two or three
decades the next two or three decades is
going to be all about genetic technology
what do you recommend to someone in high
school what should they focus on what
should they study what are good majors
to be in uh and what what do you think
the careers will be like you know as you
go in uh the decades ahead
thanks for the question carol i you know
there's so many opportunities for young
folks who are getting into science right
now or thinking about about that you
know is this science of the right career
for me and like you said sal i think you
know it's it's just i think many of us
that are working in this field feel that
there is uh there are just exploding
opportunities there's many many things
that were difficult to do even a year or
two ago that we're now able to do as
scientists you know in terms of our
research
so for students i would say you know
pursue your i always tell my my own
students my own son you know pursue your
passions
and uh if it's if it's biology that that
you get really excited about you know
pursue that if it's chemistry for me it
was it was chemistry in those early days
you know and wanting to understand how
molecules work
and i've always found for myself that
you know by by really
following my own kind of gut feelings
about things you know what i what i felt
really uh passionately excited about
studying
that has always led me in interesting
directions not always directions that i
could have predicted either which kind
of makes uh make science fun
absolutely and maybe my my last question
i am curious you know i
i mean how does it feel i mean do you
ever sit there and you know look in the
mirror and say yeah i just changed
humanity forever
well i have to say that you know when we
were first doing this research in the
laboratory there were a number of
moments for me where i was kind of
pinching myself and saying you know
is this really happening i mean you know
this is it seemed kind of fantastical to
think that bacteria had evolved a system
for detecting viruses that we could then
figure out how it worked in the
laboratory and that that insight would
then allow us to harness it as a
powerful technology so you know it was
really an incredible experience to to be
involved in that and um yeah again i to
me i would just again getting back to
why i'm a scientist and and why i think
it's such a wonderful career you know
for for uh students that are thinking
about this it's you know it's a way to
continue to have the kind of uh
curiosity driven
passions that you have when you're
growing up you know and you get to as a
scientist you know people still pay me
to you know uh ask questions and try to
figure out how things work so it's it's
uh it's really a fun career
no well you can you can feel the energy
and i mean
i think it makes sense because you are
literally changing
the world uh and you know the people
speak in hyperbolic terms about a lot of
things about what you have done i do
think in 100 or 200 years a lot of what
we're doing in our current time might be
forgotten but this is going to be one of
these things that will change i
hopefully and i believe forever
positively humanity uh so thank you so
much for your work and thank you for
joining us and inspiring us
thanks for inviting me sal great to be
here
so thanks everyone for for joining uh if
if you couldn't tell i was a little bit
uh star struck uh for for anyone who's
who has followed what's been going on in
biology and chemistry over the last
several years what jennifer's work with
her colleagues uh is really
it's it's a it's going to be a big deal
and you're only going to hear more and
more about it so uh look i encourage you
if any of what we said is confusing uh
definitely you can uh review the the the
foundations on khan academy on your
chemistry and your the biology on khan
academy but i encourage you to look into
that because i have a feeling in in many
fields especially if you're going into
biotech or medicine the work jennifer's
work and crispr is going to be a central
element so it's a good thing to get uh
to get smart on uh so with that thanks
so much for joining and i will see all
of y'all uh i believe next week i
i live day to day i i don't know what
i'm doing tomorrow uh but i will see
y'all have a good day
you